how much anxiety or even fear do you
have before making a difficult decision
on the chessboard so it's a high stakes
game
how nervous do you get how much anxiety
do you have and all that calculations
you're sitting there for 10-15 minutes
because you're in a fog there's always
the possibility of a blunder of a
mistake are you anxious about it are you
afraid of it really depends
um I have been I have been at times
I think the most nervous I ever been was
game 10 of
the world championships in 2018. I
though that was just a thrilling game
I was black
um I basically abandoned the queen side
at some point to attack him on the king
side and I knew that
my attack if it doesn't work I'm gonna
lose but I had so much adrenaline so
that was that was fine I thought I was
going to win then at some point I
realized that it's not so clear and then
my time was ticking and I was just
getting so nervous I I still remember
what happened like we played this time
trouble phase where he had Fair little
time but I had even less
and I just remember I kind of remember
much of it just that when it was over I
was just so relieved because then it was
clear the position was probably gonna
figure out the num in a draw otherwise
I'm often nervous before games but when
I get there
it's all business and especially when
I'm playing well I'm never afraid of of
losing when I when I play because I
trust yeah I trust my instincts I trust
my uh my skills how much psychological
intimidation is there from you to the
other person from the other person to
you
I think people would play a lot better
if they played against an anonymous me I
would love to are people are scared of
you I I would love to have a tournament
online
where let's say you play 10 of the best
players in the world
and you don't for each round you don't
know who you're playing
would be
that's an interesting question you know
like there's these like videos where
people eat McDonald's or Burger King or
Diet Coke versus Diet Pepsi would people
be able to tell they're playing you
uh like from the style of play do you
think or from the strength of play
if there was a decent sample size sure
um and what about you would you be able
to tell uh others inter in like just one
game
very unlikely what what sample size
would you need to tell accurately I feel
like this is science yeah I I think 20
games would help a lot per person yeah
but uh I know that they've already
developed AI Bots that are pretty good
at recognizing somebody's Style
okay I was just um which is quite
fascinating uh
and they'd be fascinating if those Bots
were able to summarize the style somehow
maybe great attacking chess like some of
the same characteristics you've been
describing like great at Short yeah line
calculations all that kind of stuff
[ __ ] no but really all the best chess
players there are basically just two
camps people who are good at long longer
lines or
or shorter lines it's the hair and the
Tortoise basically and sometimes you
know
I feel like I'm the closest you can get
to a a hybrid of those
because you got both the you're good in
every position so the middle game and
the end game yeah and also I can I I can
think to some extent both rapidly and
deeply which a lot of people they can't
do both um but I mean to to answer your
question from before I think yeah I
sometimes can get a little bit
intimidated by my opponent but
it's mostly if there's something unknown
if it's mostly if if it's something that
I don't understand fully and I I do
think especially when I'm playing well
people they just play more timidly
against me than they do against each
other sometimes
without even realizing it and I
certainly use that to my my advantage if
I sense that my opponent is apprehensive
if I sense that
they're not gonna necessarily take all
their chances it just means that I can
take more risk and
um I always try and try and find that
balance to shake them up a little bit
yeah